hello and welcome to the new world
review where it has been a long arc of
hunter hunter and so it is time for some
steaming good thoughts
i said steaming good thoughts like
steamed buns but thoughts i steam you
steam we all steam for hisoka's steamed
schwing
which is cleverly covered up by this
subscribe button hit the button and it
goes from schwing to
the unfortunate grey of an unfulfilled
swing thing leave my darling hisoka
unfulfilled then give him a thumbs up of
amused victory that's right take away
his fun then kick him while he's okay
i i feel bad just like and subscribe and
let's move on to looking at episodes 58
and 59
of hunter hunter it feels like the big
brother house all up in here or
i'm a phantom trooper get me out of here
we got to see a lot of
really lovely story lines close up or
tie up or
you know something like that and said a
sad farewell to pakunoda
the fortunes are changing and crollo
can't lead the spider anymore
i would love to know what cruella's
thinking but the nature of the character
is that we don't know what he's thinking
unless he says it so we have to make
educated guesses
my bet is that he's not mad but probably
pained having spent so long trying to
instill a philosophy in the troop
instead what happened is he created
emotions and engendered caring and love
in his people
pakinota killed herself to pass on the
information to the others uvogin died
rather than give them away the others
didn't follow pakinoda because of the
values he held but they only
held those values because they cared
enough about him and respected him
enough to hold them once pakinota was
dead and they knew why
she'd done what she did they didn't even
pretend to be living by his values
instead splitting the way the troop does
to find a way to help him
they know they can't kill kurapika
because that might have repercussions on
crollow so they're just going to live
with the knowledge that they have a
serial killer after them who they
believe or may not believe wants to pick
them off one by one
depending on how they interpret what
pakinoda passes on to them and does
kurapaka actually want to kill them
i don't think so i think he wants
revenge and there are things
worse than death separating crollow from
the rest of the troop cuts him off from
the values he held he can find a way to
deal with that blade on his heart
but he won't because he values his life
more than pakinoda valued hers
which is interesting isn't it ultimately
crolo sees it as more
valuable for him to find a way to
circumvent what's been done to him
or to simply live the life he's been
left with krapika knew
when he took pakinota onto the ship that
this was exactly what would happen but
there was no way around it and so he did
what he needed to
meanwhile hisoka also did what he needed
to which unfortunately resulted in the
anti-swing his dick inverted a sight
that entertained me more than i could
possibly have anticipated the lack of
color and the stillness of the frame was
so
perfectly descriptive of that invert
that even though i suspected what the
outcome might be
the reward was worth so much more than
what i imagined
meanwhile he allowed gon and kilwa to
escape and the others simply watched
from the window as the only possible
alternative to his schwing
satiation was taken from him floating
away with the clouds
there was something great about the fact
that his entire membership of the troop
was removed which meant that he could
spend
time with hisoka in the first place if
crollow had thought that
would put him in danger it was a nice
reveal for him but crollo doesn't bloody
tell us what he's thinking anyway so
it's
it wasn't as delicious reveal as it
could have been i want more delicious
reveals
from crollo specifically huh it still
doesn't actually explain to us how
people join the troupe is it the tattoo
that makes them a member is it the
induction
what exactly does it i'm hoping that
information becomes clear at some point
because it's very obvious that this
thread of story isn't quite
over the fact that they still haven't
made it to dumpland is an indication of
that
the fact that crowl's headed east as an
indication of that where is
east we haven't been given an overall
map with their locations have we
probably
if we have liam can show it now back to
pekinota
she was proof that the phantom trooper
just wayward kids looking for a place in
the world
the moment with the kitten and her
saying hello to it was a beautiful touch
and let's not forget she broke uh i've
already forgotten his name
that guy's arm from a day ago squalor
she's not a good person but the
important point and
one i guess this series is really trying
to drum into me at the moment
is that this world is full of not good
people that doesn't mean they're bad
people
just that they're not good people trying
to make their way through the world
however they can
they're all not good people trying to
achieve their goals
it just so happens that everyone else is
trying to achieve goals that conflict
with theirs
so they often kill them because that's
the best way to achieve their goals they
have the same moral code as korapika and
gone as shown by slick and shady
thanking them at the auction kilwa and
hisoka are their own creature but they
also don't necessarily kill unless
something is specifically in their way
or it's actually just really really fun
if you were to replace that action the
killing part with literally any healthy
way of behaving they'd all be normal
people but i guess that's the point
they're not healthy or normal people and
they have magical powers
i guess so that's another thing that's
what elevates them above the level of
say your average hunter exam entrance
the fact that they are also being guided
by fate is an interesting one
as their fate shifts there's no way for
them to read it anymore crollo's out for
the count neon is knocked out or
otherwise disabled
kurabika has a fever now that red eye
really got him he maintained it for a
very long time in fairness and he knew
from the last time that he really
shouldn't do that i wonder what will
happen from here
essentially he has cut the head off the
spider but he also knows that pakinoda
would sacrifice herself
to get the information to the right
people he specifically instinctively
knows that
so what's he gonna do there's no point
in hunting down the members right now
and he really can't he's too weak so i
guess
we shift focus back to greed island
unless something else turns up to
sidequest them maybe it's time for
leorio to have a sidequest shift into
main quest territory there's only one
way to find out
episode 59 well episode 59 and we are
into a denouement gone
and killer are hiding information from
kurapika who still knocked out
these episodes are always interesting
because they often give us a bit of down
time before carrying us into a new
story or moment i find them sort of
oddly paced because we immediately went
from one arc to the next and into a new
intro and outro sequence even this time
which is great it's great to have
confirmation that the arc has finished
and we're in a new story
but the arc shift itself felt a bit
abrupt it's a really fine line but with
so much
emotionally unfinished i struggled and
maybe it's because i essentially watched
a season finale and a season opener this
week but it was a little jarring
maybe it wouldn't have been if i timed
the episodes better i mean i can blame
myself but
looking back slightly i didn't go into
this last episode because i thought it
would be better placed here and i think
i'm sort of right at the end of last
episode we got gone and keelar acting
like kids again sitting around eating
snacks with kilowatt's magical
constantly growing wardrobe proving that
he is in fact
the height of fashion bringing up the
plan gone had what feels like a really
long time ago but was in fact only a
couple of days
it's interesting that gone can have such
an incredible plan but failed to think
about what he'd want as a special skill
i'm not entirely sure what to class
gone's intelligence as because
as fun as it is to say he's a dunce he's
actually not despite the show constantly
deciding to push him into that trope
he thinks fast on his feet but he also
thinks very practically based on the
contextual information he has which
means it's not all
instinctive the plan he came up with to
get into greed island was a good one and
yes
while i've probably flip-flopped on his
intelligence several times the gap
between gone as an intelligent
caring character and gone as a
buffoonish psychopath is a really odd
dichotomy to have to deal with
episode by episode and yes we could wave
a magic wand and say
yes waifu turns out people are complex
and it is possible to write
three-dimensional characters
there is a limit to the extent that that
feels consistent and
works the brain frying experience he has
i could almost understand if he hadn't
shown his ability to think quickly in
the last few episodes
and to ask really competent questions
that were in fact so competent and clear
that kielwa commented on the usefulness
of having someone around who wasn't
afraid to ask them gone
is not a buffoon kilwa is also not a
buffoon
kilwa is more childlike than gone
because we see in kilwa the drive to
prove himself intelligent by over
correcting his attempts at being grown
up
basically he tries so hard to look and
act grown up that he presents us younger
and there is something very charming
about that
the power that kilwa decides to define
as his own is so perfectly his and calls
back wonderfully to what he said to the
guy in the tournament
about how he was used to electrical
torture it's a good choice and works
very well with his color scheme
meanwhile
gone's signature power becoming power
fists is also
very much in keeping with his own
goku-like hair and demeanor
sometimes i wonder whether he was in
fact styled after goku from dragon ball
because the buffoonery doesn't seem to
fit him as much as i want it to
then combined with the power punch she
seems to be building in his hairstyle
i'm waiting for weighted clothes y'all
just saying or maybe
wait which came first the goku or the
gone i'm gonna say that probably the
gone
actually which means goku stop copying
it's cheating although you grew up
faster which is good i guess
with a new arc comes new really
important characters and i have to say
that i'm sorry in advance
i didn't learn the names of the
characters before it was great to see
chicken wing and sushi sushi but i
really
didn't learn any other names and i'm
already overloaded by white eyebrow guy
so i don't hold out a great deal of hope
for anyone except hisoka and maybe
blonde and curly whenever we meet her
probably in game this arc based on the
intro only
seems like it's going to take a dip into
the pokemon world we're going to do some
item collecting we're going to do some
choosing of people and characters we've
got to collect some hunter cards and
maybe we'll see
[Music]
and maybe we'll see jing maybe we'll see
ging maybe we'll see jing
wait the way the intro ends it looks
like they're working with hisoka is that
true
is that a thing that's going to happen
if so i'm intrigued it also looks like
we're setting up for them
not to have any contact with leorio and
kurapika are we having a couple
of the group take a break it makes sense
give corapica a break and let leorio
finish learning to be a doctor while
they get in there and do their own
kid-like growth stuff
oh before i forget there was really no
payoff unless it's coming and we haven't
got there yet to piggy getting to the
auction
kyoa had a moment of recognition and
from there nothing at all happened and
it was kind of
it felt like a huge waste of energy and
time i really hope it comes back but
after all that it sort of was just
unfocused and annoyed me a little bit
but there are going to be some of the
phantom troop in the game with them is
interesting because either they'll come
together to get out or they're going to
become the next
major rivals of the next arc either way
the two of them will return leaving
the rest of the troop outside yay i
don't really know how i feel about them
given they were my least favorite
characters of this arc so it'll be good
to get to know them maybe
i guess and before i sign off for this
episode let's discuss the chibi
animations
i love when they use little cute chippy
animations to
highlight the oddity of things and to
educate cute little struggling
karapika cute little hallucinating
kurapika
what licking and eating and choking or
chinese so
cute we're going to get to learn a
little something from cute gone and
quilla each time
liam i want a chibi me make a cute chibi
me please i am ready because that's it
from me
if you enjoyed this episode feel free to
click here here and here
if you want to see more as it arrives
feel free to hit the subscribe and bell
thing i guess and come hang out in the
discord server
thumbs up for a chibi waifu too